i was an economist before joining the
army and my understanding is that
progressives don't want to socialize the
economy but just the public good sector
of the economy things like prisons
police health care military fire
departments that belong in the in the
public sector according to economists
um
am i correct chris is asking or do you
actually want to socialize the entire
economy
oh well
i i don't want to socialize the entire
economy um now
let me just note that i don't speak for
all socialists in fact there's a lot of
disagreement among socialists about uh
how
they would like society to appear so let
me just be clear about what i support
and what i would want i think there are
certain sectors of our economy that
should be decommodified
including healthcare education um you
know i'm pretty open about that on
the programming that i do
but in terms of markets
i i have a
i don't have a problem with private
companies i do have a problem though
with the uh power dynamic uh among the
the way that i would classify it is you
know you have two classes you have the
capitalist class you have the working
class right and so the power dynamic is
just completely off right now where the
working class has no power um i'd like
to change that so that's why i'm so
excited to see uh the emergence of
worker co-ops within the united states i
think that's the right way to go um the
other way historically that uh
labor has found solutions in this
country is by organizing and forming
labor unions um and ensuring that you
know they had the power structure
necessary to do general strikes which uh
applied pressure to fdr and led to the
new deal i think that you know that's
what i was talking about regarding not
having to reinvent the wheel um but
yeah i think that there are
opportunities for private companies that
i'm totally fine with but certain things
i do consider to be human rights
including health care including
education and there shouldn't be a
profit motive and by the way including
our justice system we shouldn't have
private prisons um i don't consider
private prisons i'm sorry prison's a
human right but i do think that you
should take the profit motive out of the
prison system because private prisons
have not worked out so well for society
so far
i mean so obviously i don't consider
profit mode of a dirty ward in fact i
think the profit motive is one of the
single greatest things that has ever
happened to humanity is when people
began to realize that that
innovation was going to create greater
wealth for them and for the people who
actually got their products this is one
of the things that has progressed
humanity just enormously since the
beginning of the 1800s the profit motive
is a wonderful wonderful thing it is not
it is not a negative thing now it
depends on what you're talking about
though um it wasn't wasn't a positive
thing in texas with their privatized
deregulated power grid
which led to 210 texans dying because
they didn't want to spend the money
necessary to weatherize their equipment
so there are certain areas where profit
motive is in fact a dirty word well so i
want to just clarify no i mean when the
state is involved with profit motive
then you have a real problem the state
paying for power for example or when you
have the state driving regulations
toward for example green energy and
subsidizing particularly less effective
forms of energy because they have an
incentive in order to do so that is not
paid off for by the risk they take that
also drives some really bad incentive
structures but profit motive is a
general rule listen i agree that there
are certain places where i'm not i'm not
particularly interested in profit being
the main driver of human activity
however the notion that that using
profit motive is sort of the all-purpose
it's a dirty word it's a bad thing and
and if there's a profit motive involved
this is what makes it bad as opposed to
bad administration or bad running of a
company they're good companies they're
bad companies it ain't the profit motive
that makes them so profit motive is
universal to human behavior because
people prefer to see the receipts of
their labor when it comes to
unionization obviously we have wide
differences on on unionization i think
that the the law is extraordinarily
biased since the nlra
against the the so-called capitalist
class i don't think the capitalist class
exists in opposition to the worker class
i don't think that my workers uh you
know the the people who work for my
company exist in opposition to me i
think that i
you know
i i really don't know many people who
run businesses who are out to
quote unquote exploit their labor and
treat them like garbage i don't think
that that is something that they wake up
seeking to do i think that in fact what
the what private business has done is
drive competition for labor in ways that
nonprivate industry has never done
public companies are
public
publicly owned companies uh
particularly nationalized industries are
not famous for treating their workers
extraordinarily well uh the the notion
that private companies treat their
workers horrifically and that all labor
is exploitative except if you work for
the government which doesn't have any
incentive to treat you well at all
because you obviously can't do anything
it's the government uh is is i think
wrong i'm not opposed to unions so long
as they're not kneecapping people or so
long as they're not forcing anybody into
a labor arrangement they don't wish to
work under um but the notion that the
the labor arrangements ought to be
general on behalf of people who have not
voluntarily signed up for the labor
arrangement seems to be skewed
yeah i mean i'm just saying uh you know
in my opinion uh well let me just note
that
as an employer right it's not that you
you have to be awful to your employees
but
you have a fiduciary responsibility to
your shareholders to return
you know to provide a return on their
investment that's literally like it's
baked into the system that's true and so
as a result i mean what's the most
expensive uh cost within a business it's
always labor it's always labor
exploitation always makes it seem like
you're actively brutal and awful to your
employees which in some cases that does
happen but it doesn't even have to get
that far the whole point is to extract
as much labor for the lowest possible
price that can only happen in order to
increase profits and provide a return of
investments to your shareholders that's
just the way the system works that's
wrong it's an economic fallacy that
there's an impoverishment of workers
that goes on under a laissez-faire
capitalist system in which companies are
actually competing for a commodity labor
is a commodity when you have companies
that are competing for the same labor
the price of labor goes up this is one
of the great fallacies of marxist theory
is that there would be a general
impoverishment of workers that would
lead to the workers of the world rising
the fact is the living standards in
industrial countries have been rising
steadily into that living standards in
non-industrialized country
non-capitalist countries have been crap
for nearly all of human history